yeah Brett Minh before you leave will
you say hi to my niece she's your
biggest fan shut this yeah yeah see
something I love me too about I love you
mom oh sweet buddy thank you so much for
saying hi to this one okay she's a
little [ __ ] so Make A Wish make a
wish pounding out of your chest right
now I've never seen her eyes get so big
I know she's got like Ghostly on me yes
thank you so much for being on tiger
barely buddy I love you so much
yeah okay let's collect we collaborate
okay yeah okay
oh yeah pretty very pretty thank you
guys I love you so much Batman I love
him so much he's great
we love him now I've always loved him I
know but I'm like you love him more was
Giuliana actually are you mad that guy
called you [ __ ] in front of him or
not is your heart beating out your chest
[Laughter]
let me just say that was the most
endearing thing I'd ever seen because
like Jules is so unemotional she's very
straight face like she has like we we
call her a flagella for for a reason
like there's no peaks and ebbs to
anything it's kind of Jewell says right
here forever and ever so when I see her
get riled up and like seemingly out of
breath oh it's a treat for us
it's a treat oh saying that was all
worth it just say hi to him I've never
seen you bug-eyed it like that before
its eyes and get that big I didn't
either it was like it went up to the
back of your head your eyes see what all
wanting yeah yeah you know what do I get
that way yeah I get that you there's
certain people that I just start like I
just started saying things I don't know
you know I mean who would like for me I
there are certain people that I I would
absolutely lose my breath over like
who's who's yours well okay so I've been
like I've been texting Joey Santiago a
lot right he's from the Pixies you know
I grew up with the Pixies yeah the band
he was my favorite band and sometimes he
texted me I'll text him back and then he
won't text me for two days back and for
two days I'll be like oh I'll just text
him again or you know I mean I still I
get fan girlie you know there's a lot of
guys like that when Paul banks he's been
on our podcast he texted me I get really
like hey what do you think of this baby
I guess this too much is this too French
and that and then there's some guys that
are big like I'll go [ __ ] you I don't
give a [ __ ] yeah you may just depends
with the whole Paul Banks thing I always
tell him Bobby I'm like just enough with
a ping-pong stop asking him to play for
you you know but you know I think that
it's if you don't have that kind of like
excitement and curiosity and and and
you're not in all with anybody and you
think you're the [ __ ] I don't think
that's a good place to be no I like
being I like being a fan as well I love
being a family right now I am obsessed
with something new that I may not ever
recover from have moved on from kdramas
and I have graduated back into the real
world of blemishes and pimples